The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN OPPENHEIM: In several
of the previous lessons,
we've focused
primarily on the class
of linear shift-invariant
systems that
are representable by linear
constant coefficient difference
equations.
And we've talked, for example,
about methods for solving
that class of equations.
One of the reasons why a linear
constant coefficient difference
equations represent a
particularly important class
of discrete time systems
is because of the fact
that they have a particularly
straightforward implementation
in terms of digital components.
So in this lecture, and actually
over the next several lectures,
what I'd like to
focus on is that class
of linear
shift-invariant systems
and in particular
the implementation
of that class of
systems, in other words,
digital networks for the
implementation of systems
describable by linear constant
coefficient difference
equations.
Well, as we have
defined previously,
an n-th order linear constant
coefficient difference equation
essentially corresponds
to a linear combination
of delayed output sequences set
equal to a linear combination
of delayed input sequences.
This is the general form for
a linear constant coefficient
difference equation,
which as we discussed
in one of the early
lectures, actually Lesson 3,
corresponds to an
explicit input output
description for the system.
In other words, we can
solve this equation
by taking this set of terms
over to the right-hand side
of the equation.
And the difference
equation that results
is a statement that
says that y of n,
the output sequence
for the system,
is a linear combination
of past outputs
plus a linear combination
of delayed inputs.
Now, we also discussed
at that point
in one of the early
lectures the fact
that a linear constant
coefficient difference
equation is not a unique
description for a system.
In other words, we saw that
this system, or a system that
satisfies this equation, could
correspond to a causal system.
Or, in fact, it could correspond
to a non-causal system,
depending on the initial
conditions or the boundary
conditions that we
impose on the equation.
We could in particular impose
the boundary conditions implied
by the statement that
the system is causal,
or we could impose
boundary conditions
implied by the statement that
the system is non-causal.
For this discussion, for the
discussion in this lecture
and actually over the
next several lectures,
the assumption will
always be that we're
talking about a causal system.
In other words, the boundary
conditions that we're imposing
is that for the input 0
for n less than, say, n1,
the output will also be
0 for n less than n1.
So we're implying a set
of boundary conditions
by virtue of the fact that
we're assuming that we're
talking about causal systems.
Now, in implementing
a system describable
by a difference equation
of this form, what we see
is that there are three basic
operations that are involved.
We have to somehow
generate delayed sequences.
We have to get y of n delayed.
We have to get x of n delayed.
So one of the basic operations
is the operation of delay.
Furthermore, we need to
multiply these delayed sequences
by scalars and these delayed
sequences by scalars.
So there is the additional
operation of multiplication.
And third, we have to
accumulate these sums,
or accumulate these products.
And so the third
operation that is required
in the implementation of a
linear constant coefficient
difference equation is
the operation of addition.
Consequently, if we were to
think of basic digital network
elements, we could choose
as our basic elements
the operations corresponding
to delay, multiplication,
and addition.
In particular what we'd like
to develop, or generate,
is a graphical representation
of the difference equation,
which is what we'll refer
to as the digital network.
So in essence, what we want
is a graphical representation
of these three operations,
which we'll combine together
into a digital network.
One type of notation,
which is essentially
block diagram
notation, corresponds
to representing the
operation of delay as a box.
The input, of course,
is the sequence
that we want to delay,
let's say, x of n.
And the output then is
that sequence delayed
by one sample, x of n minus 1.
And typically in the
block diagram type
of representation, this element,
or block, is denoted with a z
to the minus 1.
Well, what does z
to the minus 1 have
to do with the
operation of delay?
Simply that if we were to think
of the z transform of the input
sequence and the z transform
of the output sequence,
what we know is that
those are related,
in fact, by multiplication
by z to the minus 1.
So the implication in
putting inside the box
the notation z to the
minus 1, the implication
is that essentially
what this block is doing
is multiplying the z transform
of the input sequence by z
to the minus 1.
So that's one element.
The second element
that we need is
the element for multiplication.
And typically,
that's denoted simply
by a line with an arrow on it.
The input to this
branch is x of n.
Or it could be,
of course, y of n.
The output of the branch is that
multiplied by a scalar, let's
say, a, the scalar a.
And this should be x of n.
If we're talking
about x of n in,
we're talking about x of n
out, or a times x of n out.
And the branch transmittance
then is the coefficient a.
So this branch allows for
coefficient multiplication.
And finally the third
element that we want
is an element that
will perform addition.
And that element is the noted
in block diagram notation
as a summer with two
inputs and a single output.
The input, let's say, x1
and x2, then the output
would be x1 plus x2
of n or z, depending
on how we choose to
describe the sequence.
Now in the difference
equation, of course,
we had to accumulate
a number of turns.
In other words, there
was more than one term
that we were adding up.
Typically, in either
digital hardware
or on a digital computer,
when we're forming additions,
the additions are
formed in pairs.
In other words, we accumulate
a large number of terms
by adding two terms together,
then adding one to that
and adding another
one to that, etc.
So it's convenient in that
sense to think of the addition
as always being a two
input one output addition.
Of course, if we
accumulate three terms,
then it would require
two adders to do that.
So these then are
the basic elements
that correspond
to a block diagram
representation of a linear
constant coefficient difference
equation, or
equivalently correspond
to a digital network.
And for example, if we had
a first order difference
equation, let's say
the equation y of n
is equal to a times y
of minus 1 plus x of n,
we can represent that
equation graphically
in terms of these elements
as I've indicated here.
So what do we have?
Well, we have as an input x
of n, as an output y of n.
We need in implementing
this difference equation
to obtain y of n minus 1.
And that's obtained
with the delay element.
y of n minus 1 is
then multiplied
by the coefficient a.
So here, we have a
times y of n minus 1.
And then the difference
equation states that y of n
is the sum of that
with the input.
And so that goes into the adder.
And out comes y of n.
So this then corresponds to a
block diagram representation
of the difference
equation, or equivalently,
a digital network in
block diagram notation.
This notation, in fact,
is a very common type
of notation for graphically
representing a difference
equation, or digital network.
There is an
alternative notation,
which has a number of
important advantages, which
is very much like the
block diagram with just
a few minor changes, which
turn out in some instances
to be convenient.
And that is the
graphical representation
of the difference equation,
or the digital network,
in terms of signal flow graphs.
Well let me introduce the
notation of signal flow graphs
first in general and then
more specifically as it
applies to your constant
coefficient difference
equations.
A signal flow graph is
essentially by definition
a network of directed branches,
which are connected at nodes.
So what that says is that in
a signal flow graph we have
what will refer to
as nodes and directed
branches, in other words
branches with arrows on them.
The nodes will be numbered.
And so, for example, we would
have a node j and a node k.
Furthermore, each
node in the network
has a variable
associated with it.
So that, for example the j
node has the variable w sub j.
The k node has the
variable w sub k.
And we have a branch going
between the j-th node
and the k-th node,
which will be referred
to as the jk-th branch.
So essentially the
numbering of the nodes
allows us to refer
to the nodes and also
to refer to the branches,
referring to the branches
by talking about which nodes
the branches go between.
The nodes that
I've indicated here
correspond to what we'll
refer to as network nodes.
There are also source nodes.
And I've indicated one here.
A source node is a node that
has no branches coming into it,
only branches leaving it.
And the opposite,
namely a sink node,
which is a node that has
no branches going out
of it and only branches
coming into it.
Basically, it's
these type of nodes
that allow us to get
inputs into the network.
It's this type of node that
we use to represent outputs
from the network.
Now, this defines
essentially the notation.
It doesn't yet specify what
the algebraic construction
of a signal flow graph is.
So in particular,
there are some rules
that tell us how the node
variables are related
to inputs and
outputs of branches
or equivalently the inputs
and outputs of other nodes.
A branch, the
jk-th branch, which
originate at node j,
terminates at node k,
has as its input, the
variable of the node
that it originates from.
It also has an output.
The output we will
denote as v sub jk.
That's the output
of the jk-th branch.
And what it is very simply
in the most general sense,
the most general
context, is some function
of the input to the branch.
So the output of a
branch is some function
of the input to
the branch, where
this function is different, of
course, for different branches.
Finally, to get the values
of the node variables,
the node values
are defined to be
equal to the sum of the
outputs of the branches
entering the node.
So that if we were to
look up here, for example,
this node variable would
be equal to the output
of this branch plus the
output of that branch.
And that's essentially
the algebraic construction
of flow graphs.
It's also convenient to
separate notationally
the output of the branches
from an internal node
to another internal
node, or from a network
node to a network node, from the
output of those branches that
originate at sources
and go to network nodes.
And the notation that we'll
use is sub jk corresponding
to the output of the branch
that goes from the j-th source--
the sources being
numbered differently
from the network nodes--
going from the j-th source
to the k-th network node.
OK, so what this says, and this
equation in particular says,
that algebraically
the node variables
are specified as the
k-th node variable
being equal to the sum over the
internal nodes of the output
of the branches from the
network nodes to the k-th node
plus the output of the
branches from the j-th
over all the source nodes,
from the j-th source node,
to the network node
that we're focusing on.
So this corresponds to
the output of the branches
from the network nodes.
And this corresponds to
the output of the branches
from the source nodes.
Well, for linear constant
coefficient difference
equations, we don't need
all of the generality
that we've implied in
the discussion so far.
In particular, what
we can concentrate
on is a special set
of signal flow graphs,
namely signal flow
graphs which are linear.
And what we mean by linear is
that the output of a branch
is equal to the input
to the branch multiplied
by some function.
So that it's a linear
relationship between the branch
output in the branch input.
In other words v sub jk, the
output of the branch from
the j-th node to the k-th node,
is equal to some function--
this might be simply a scalar
or it might be a function of z,
for example, which it will
often turn out to be--
multiplied by the
input to that branch,
in other words, the
value of the j-th node.
So that is then the
additional constraint
that we impose if we're talking
about linear signal flow
graphs, which we'll
be concentrating
on for the rest of the lecture.
Well, to see how a linear
constant coefficient difference
equation can be represented
in terms of linear signal flow
graphs, let's take the
same example that we worked
with previously in terms of
the block diagram notation,
in other words, y of n is
equal to a times y of n minus 1
plus x of n.
Well, we have a node
that's a source node.
That's x of n.
We have a node
that's a sink node.
That's y of n.
That's what we'd like to
get out of the network.
And presumably somehow we've
gotten a network node whose
value will be y of n minus 1.
If we have that node, then what
we want to form to get y of in
is a times y of n minus 1.
So we want y of
minus 1 multiplied
by a, which means that this
branch has a transmittance,
or a gain, which is a.
And then because of the
algebraic definition at nodes,
the value of this node
is the sum of this branch
and the output of this branch.
So if this branch
has a gain of unity,
then this node variable
will have the value x of n
plus a times y the minus 1.
Well, now we simply have to
get from here all the way
out to there.
I've drawn it, the network,
somewhat inefficiently.
I can get from this node to this
node simply with a unity gain.
From this node to the
output node again,
with the unity gain.
And now the only question is--
of course, if this is y of n,
and this node has value y of n
also--
how do I get from
this node to this node
if I'm talking about a
linear signal flow graph?
Well, y of n minus
1, of course, isn't
a scalar multiplied by y of n.
But y of z, or the z transform
rather of y of n minus 1
is actually a scalar or
a function multiplied
by the z transform of y of n.
So if I were to think of
this rather than in terms
of the sequences, if I were
to think of this in terms
of this transform, then in fact
the z transform at this node
would be z to the
minus 1 times y of z.
And consequently, thinking
of it in terms of z
transforms, the
gain of this branch
then is z to the minus 1.
So this, in fact
does, correspond
to multiplication
by a function of z,
as long as in the
background what we remember
is that we're essentially
thinking of the flow graph
as representing relationships
between the z transform.
Now, obviously, we wouldn't
feel constrained to designate it
that way all the time.
In other words, I would
feel very comfortable
about drawing this flow
graph and labeling this input
as x of n, labeling
this node is y of n,
and this is y of n
minus 1, and indicating
that this branch has a
transmittance of z the minus 1.
Just simply in the
background what we realize
is it's not y of n that's
multiplied by z to the minus 1.
It's y of z that's multiplied
by z to the minus 1.
Also, notationally,
it's usually convenient,
since very often we end up with
branches that have unity gain,
to choose the convention
that if a branch doesn't have
the game labeled on it, the
implication is that what
the gain is, in fact, is unity.
So generally, actually we won't
specify explicitly unity gain.
If there is a branch
with unity gain,
we simply won't label the gain.
One final point and that is
that you can, I think, see--
you probably observed this
for yourself already--
that actually this flow graph
is drawn somewhat inefficiently
as I've indicated here.
Basically, I can
take these two nodes
and collapse them together.
I chose to draw this
flow graph this way so
that it looks as much like the
block diagram representation as
possible.
And in fact, if you compare
it back to the block diagram
representation, it is basically
the same except for the fact
that we've chosen to
represent this delay
branch a little differently.
And we've used the algebra
of signal flow graphs
to do the addition at nodes
rather than explicitly putting
in an adder.
And that's really
the only difference.
Now, what a flow graph
or a block diagram
is, as I've stressed, is
a graphical representation
of that difference equation.
And what it in
turn corresponds to
is a graphical representation
of a linear set of equations,
a set of equations, which
describe the relationships
among the various variables
or among the nodes
in the digital network.
If I were, for example, going
to implement a difference
equation or a single flow graph
on a digital computer, what
I would implement in
effect is not the graphics
of the signal flow graph.
I would implement the algebra
In other words,
I would implement
the linear set of equations that
the flow graph corresponds to.
Consequently, what
I'd like to spend
the remainder of
the lecture on is
focusing on the equivalent
linear set of equations
that the signal flow graph
corresponds to, in other words,
the matrix representation
of a digital network.
And the matrix representation
is important from a number
of points of view.
One is, of course,
that as I've just
stressed it's important for
the actual implementation
of the digital network.
It's also important
in a sense that lots
of properties of
digital networks
fall out from the
properties of matrices.
We won't, in fact, in
this set of lectures
be exploiting that
particularly, but it
is one of the reasons why
the matrix representation
of digital networks is also
important to be aware of.
So let's then see what this
graphical representation,
or the linear single flow
graph representation,
corresponds to in terms of
a set of linear equations,
or in terms of a
set of matrices.
So we're considering
then a general network.
It has some internal nodes,
branches, coming into them.
I've indicated one source
node and one sink node.
More generally, there would
be a set of source nodes
and a set of sink nodes.
The algebraic equations that
the flow graph corresponds to
is a statement of how
the node variables are
related to each other.
And just to remind you
of how that's generated--
and I'm expressing this now
in terms of the z transforms
of the node variables--
the z transform of the k-th
node variable is the sum over
the network nodes of
the branch outputs--
that's indicated here-- plus
the sum over the source branch
outputs.
And incidentally, I've
assumed that it's just--
best to assume this because
of notational convenience--
that there's a branch
from every network node
to every other network node.
Obviously I can always
get away with that.
If that branch
doesn't really exist,
I simply set the gain of
that branch equal to zero.
Now, furthermore, we
have the relationship
that defines what
the branch output is
in terms of the branch input or
in terms of the node variables.
So we have specifically
the statement
that v sub jk, the output
of the jk-th branch,
is some function of z
multiplied by the branch input.
And furthermore, the
source branch output
is some function, or scalar,
multiplied by the source node
value.
Well, if we substitute
these two equations
into the previous
equation, which
defined what the
node values are,
we end up with a
statement that says
that the node variables are
equal to a linear combination
of the node variables, the
linear combination specified
by the branch transmit answers,
plus a linear combination
of the source node values.
And this then is a set
of linear equations
that, in essence, defines
the digital network.
This is a set of
equations, of course,
because we have an equation
like this for each value of k
as k runs over all the
network nodes, in other words,
for k starting from 1
and running up to n.
We can express the set of linear
equations in matrix notation.
If we think of a column
vector corresponding
to the node variables,
then this equation
says that the vector or column
matrix of node variables
is equal to a matrix of
coefficients dictated
by the branch transmittances
multiplied again
by the node variables plus
a second matrix multiplied
by the column of
source node values.
And there is one peculiar thing
that happens notationally here,
which it's worthwhile
to straighten out.
It happens because
of the way that we
chose to write these equations
that the branch transmittance
values come in to the matrix,
as I've indicated here.
So the first row, for
example, contains F 1 1,
F2 through F sub N1.
As you're well aware, typically
in defining a matrix and matrix
elements, the
general convention is
to refer to the matrix
elements with the first index
corresponding to the
row, the second index
corresponding to the column.
So the tendency is to refer to
the matrix elements as A1 1,
A 1 2 through A 1N, etc.
So that simply means that in
writing this set of equations
in compact matrix form,
it's convenient to do that
by referring to the transpose
of a matrix of coefficients
rather than directly to the
matrix of coefficients itself.
In other words,
it's convenient when
I write this set of equations,
or a set of equations
in compact matrix
notation, to write it
as I've indicated here.
We have a column vector of
node values, node variables,
equal to a transpose
coefficient matrix
multiplied by the column
vector of node variables.
And then the transpose
of the transmittances
that connect the sources
to the internal network
nodes multiplied by the
source vector, where
the matrix F of z, the jk-th
element of the matrix F of z
is F sub jk of z.
I think that it takes just a few
minutes of private reflection
to see that this works
out notationally.
But it's this reason, it's to
interface the matrix notation
and the flow graph notation that
makes it convenient to refer
to the transpose, to a
transpose matrix here,
rather than omitting
the transposition.
It's typical and notationally
what will also stick with
in representing a digital
network with flow graph
notation to restrict ourselves
always to branches that are
either simply co-efficient
branches-- in other words,
they correspond to
multiplication by a scalar--
or they're simply
delay branches.
In other words, they
have a transmittance
which is z to the minus 1.
And with that restriction,
it's convenient for a number
of reasons, and in particular
for developing some network
properties, to consider
decomposing this matrix
equation in such a way that we
separate out with the matrix F
transpose of z the part of that
matrix that doesn't involve
any delay terms and the
part of that matrix that
does involve delay terms.
In particular, we can write
the transpose matrix F
transposed of z.
We can separate it into
the sum of two matrices.
One matrix is simply
a coefficient matrix.
In other words, it involves
no terms z to the minus the 1.
The second matrix
contains only terms
involving z to the minus 1.
And, of course, we can pull
the z to the minus 1 outside.
And so we have the
delay terms isolated.
In other words, we have
a matrix of coefficients
here, all of the terms
multiplied by z to the minus 1.
So the matrix f of
z can be separated
into a coefficient matrix
and a delay matrix.
And if we now substitute that
back into our original matrix
equation, then we
have the statement
that says that the
vector of node variables
is a coefficient
matrix multiplied
by that vector, a delay matrix
multiplied by that vector.
And then I'm
assuming incidentally
in this notation
and, of course, it
can be generalized quite easily
that the sources are connected
only with non-delay branches.
I have suppressed incidentally
in the discussion up
to this point, the
additional statement
that we need, the additional
set of equations that we need,
that tell us how finally
we get from the set
of internal network nodes
to the network output.
We have then an additional
set of equations
that specify what the sink
node values are in terms
of the internal network nodes.
And often in referring to the
matrix equations for a signal
flow graph, sometimes
we'll include this equation
explicitly, and sometimes
we'll tend to suppress it.
Now, looking at
this equation where
we've separated out the
coefficient and delay branches,
we can alternatively
reinterpret that equation
in the time domain.
It's expressed here in
terms of z transforms.
In the time domain, then
this corresponds again
to a matrix set of equations
stating that the column vector
w of n is equal to a
coefficient matrix multiplied
by the present state--
in other words, the
same column vector--
plus another matrix multiplied
by that set of node variables,
one iteration previously, and
then, of course, an equation
coupling the sources
into that and finally
an equation that
generates the sync node
outputs from the node variables.
But if you look at this, what
this corresponds to, of course,
is a set of first order
difference equations,
so that essentially
what we've done,
starting from our n-th order
linear constant coefficient
difference equation, through
the signal flow graph
representation, we have
in essence decomposed that
into a set of first order linear
constant coefficient difference
equations, of course,
all of them coupled.
And the discussion in
the next several lectures
will in fact involve
what the various options
are in terms of what
various forms we can use,
or are commonly
used, in representing
this large n-th order equation.
But what we see is that the
signal flow graph in essence
breaks down the
n-th order equation
into a set of first order
difference equations.
Well, let's just finally
look at an example
of how the set of equations
might look for a single flow
graph, a relatively
simple example,
and incidentally somewhat
meaningless in the sense
that it's not a flow
graph that is motivated
by anything other than something
to draw here for discussion.
Well, all right, here's a
linear signal flow graph.
It has these unity
gain branches.
It has a branch with gain
b and a branch with gain a
and the two delay branches.
According to the algebra
for the flow graph,
this node variable is equal
to B times this node variable.
So that's this equation.
This node variable is this one
delayed plus this one delayed.
That's this equation
and this node--
I'm sorry, this node is a
times w2 of n plus the source.
So those are the linear
equations defining
the internal network nodes.
And this corresponds then
to a matrix equation.
Let me draw your
attention to the fact,
incidentally, that
the way that I've
numbered these
nodes in fact is not
the order in which I can compute
them if I were to compute them
successively.
Now, what I mean
by that is suppose
that in my numbering
what I decide
is that what the numbering
means is that node 1
I'll compute first, node 2
I'll compute second, node 3
I'll compute third.
To compute node
1, I need node 3.
And I don't have
node 3 if I'm going
to compute that after node 1.
So actually the order that I've
specified here for the nodes
is not an order in which
I can compute the network.
Or another way to say that
is that this network as I've
numbered the nodes
is not computable.
But let's go on, and
we'll look in fact
at a rearrangement of the
nodes that is computable.
But let's see how the
matrix equation looks.
Simply, this equation rewritten
in terms of a set of matrices,
then it comes out as
I've indicated here.
We have the matrix F sub c.
This is the coefficient matrix.
This is the delay matrix.
So it involves a vector
of only delayed sequences
and then the input coupled in.
Let me point out incidentally--
just keep track of the
fact that this matrix,
the coefficient matrix,
happens to have an element
on or above the major diagonal.
And that shouldn't have any
particular meaning right now,
but it will in a
couple of minutes.
All right, let's consider a
slightly different ordering
for the network nodes.
This is the same network.
I now have ordered the
node slightly differently.
I'm calling this node 1,
this node 2, and this node 3.
And let's just inquire as
to whether the nodes ordered
as I've indicated here
are now computable.
Well, to get node 1, I need w
of n minus 1, which of course I
got because that's from
the previous iteration.
I need w3 of n minus 1.
And that I've got from
the previous iteration.
So this node can be computed.
To compute this node, I need
the source, which I have.
And I need w1 of n,
which I just got.
So this can be computed.
And then to compute
w3 of n, I need
w2 of n, which I just computed.
And so, in fact, the nodes
numbered in this order
are computable,
whereas the nodes
numbered in the previous
order are not computable.
If I look at the
equations for this,
they're, of course, the same
equations as I had previously,
except that some of the
indices are changed.
And so it simply
involves changing
some of the rows and columns.
And what it comes
out to look like,
in fact, is what
I've indicated here.
Again, the coefficient matrix--
the same elements appear, but
the order is swapped around--
multiplied by the vector
of current node states
and then a delay
matrix multiplied
by the vector of delayed states,
and then the input coupled in.
And notice that in this case, we
don't have any non-zero values
on or above the main diagonal.
It turns out that
you can show it,
and it's not too
difficult to do,
you can show that a necessary
and sufficient condition
for the node numbering
to correspond
to a computable network, or
to be a computer numbering,
is that this
coefficient matrix has
to have the form that there
are no non-zero elements
on or above the major diagonal.
So often if the
nodes are numbered
in a non-computable
order, the order
can simply be rearranged
so that it is computable.
It does turn out
incidentally that there
are some networks for which
no matter how you number the
nodes, you can't number them in
an order that makes the network
computable.
Computability, as
I've just said,
is the statement that the notes
can be numbered in such a way
that it's 0 above or
on the main diagonal.
As you'll see as you work some
problems in the study guide,
a non-computable network,
in essence, what happens
is that we have a set of nodes
in the network all of which
are connected together
by non-delay branches.
And so you can see that what
happens is to compute this one
I need that one.
But to compute that
when, I need this one.
But to compute this
one, I need this.
But to compute
that, I need that.
There's no way to
get out of that loop.
So if there's a delay
free loop in the network,
it turns out that
that corresponds
to a non-computable network.
Although it's
important to stress
that the
non-computability doesn't
mean that the set of
equations can't be solved,
the set of equations
can still be solved,
or the network
can be rearranged.
What it simply means is
that non-computability
means that we can't compute
the node variables in sequence.
We can't start with
w1 of n and then
go on the w2 of n and
then w3 of n, etc.
Well, this issue of
non-computability
is just one brief glimpse in
fact into the kinds of network
properties that
can be pulled out
of either the signal flow graph
representation of properties
of signal flow graphs or out
of the matrix representation.
As I indicated at the
beginning of the lecture,
we won't be exploiting
these kinds of properties.
There is, in fact, a
rather lengthy discussion
of properties of digital
networks in the text, which
we won't be going into further.
In the next several lectures
what we'll concentrate on
are the more common
digital network structures
for implementing both
infinite impulse response,
or recursive digital filters,
and finite impulse response,
or non-recursive
digital filters.
Thank you.